what happened last night because you
guys met
last night and then we'll get into the
rest of the show so you were on
the infamous fresh and fit show last
night the after-hours show ironically
she's here today that we could not set
this up like we did not plan this
yeah jenny i'm sorry amber what happened
i let and then what do you think you
want them to talk about it i don't know
you were there
jorge can you turn me up a little bit
please it's so funny i definitely
knew a little bit of what i was getting
into i knew it was going to be wild i
knew that was going to be heated and
passionate and i am a passionate person
but i have class and i have like respect
for people and so i was ready and i feel
like i held my own during the during the
conversation like i wasn't quiet
got a little heated with tommy but um i
think you guys made some very
interesting points i didn't love always
the way you presented them and i think
that you could have expanded and i'm
excited to do that here in a more calm
environment with some very educated
people next to me but um
the ending of that uh was something i've
never experienced in my life before um
that level of energy uh
uh i honestly don't even know exactly
the narrative but um one of the girls
shay
and tommy who was the special guest
we're in a very heated argument which
started about uh his content that he
posts on instagram
and it evolved i guess into a drama that
they had that i don't know if anybody
knew about we might have a clip do we
have this is it okay if we showed this
all right yeah go ahead i mean uh it's
all over the internet yeah yeah just
just be careful it's not because
this was after like four hours we were
live like
you guys go for a long time yeah yeah it
was at the end and we were like i was
hungry i was tired it was like and she
goes one more thing it was yeah three
hours and three hours in like 15 minutes
and i had to can the people see what's
going on if you when you play it yeah
yeah all right let's see what's going on
and then we'll let
can you turn the volume up we anticipate
having a long fruitful relationship with
rosetta stone several hundred band
members have already registered for
lessons well eric
have different volumes
what is that
going on you might have another tab open
that's a funny dichotomy though
several hundred band members
happens to us all the time so
it's all good man
well guys this is show business baby
trust me bro this is what happens dude
we're so used to this this is every day
like we don't even we're doing a bad
night i will say while he's pulling this
up i was on your guy's show with rolo
shout out to rolo tobacco in the house
who was here last week inviting me guys
down here and we we met thank you for
being so gracious you i mean the whole
operation that you guys are running you
were there i mean it's
anything could
it is a lot of moving parts bro yeah
yeah so
he's working hard you're just chilling
on the couch
occasionally you're social media
he's like sound problem
eric are we ready sir
oh man
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so i had to get in there you might
wanna uh he really tried to fight a girl
though i don't want to stop [ __ ] you
might want to step yeah because there's
going to be some nudity so yeah that's
all i was going to say like stop it
before that yes
at that moment we're in a very small
like space and there's
lots of rage and arms throwing and
things throwing and
fight or flight like flight
i'm trying to get out of there okay and
something happened and i've never had a
panic attack before in my life never um
but i literally couldn't breathe that
you saw me i was i couldn't i was
gasping for air and i was super
emotional because there's a huge [ __ ]
dude who's throwing fists at this girl
and she's also going crazy people are
restraining her in a very small
environment and i freaked out and you
were very sweet to me and you came and
you calmed me down and
listen i i had respect for you the whole
night but when you came over and made
fun of me i was like bro where's your
empathy you were like your life was
never in danger it didn't matter i felt
scared and you could not give a [ __ ] you
were like i'm going to make fun of you
tomorrow for that who just are you
talking about myron yeah so you're
saying fresh was nice and mine was he
was like so it's not an epiphany
myron what would you like to say about
this i know you're very opinionated dude
and then we're going to turn it over
jenny for an opinion on this too um well
i guess uh
[ __ ] your feelings i don't know man i
like it it's like it's it's just another
day in office of fresher fit man like
confrontation bringing girls into this
environment like you are you're you're
you're they're facilitating your content
and your viewership you should at least
make sure that they feel safe and in
that moment i didn't and instead of
being like hey sorry
let me just let me just frame this a
different way totally understand where
you're coming from you're my homegirl
you're on the show but i'm talking about
what happened with the gentleman and the
lady like what happened with that where
where does that stand yes okay your
feelings do matter i'm not gonna say
[ __ ] feelings however he's entitled
to his opinion yeah but what happened
with the gentleman and the lady what
they were arguing about once they
answered that basically some stuff that
he posted on his instagram she didn't
like the way he posted certain things
and he was like well i'm gonna post what
i want you could post what you want just
don't watch the content which he's right
and then she struck him first and that's
what led to all that other stuff you
know this you know she hit him first and
you know obviously i'm glad i was able
to get in there and break it up and it
was under control which is why did he
say i look at it like her
uh i mean so so yeah what's the stance
on like a chicken swings at a dude
disrespect so the guy shouldn't hit back
what's the rule on that so
we do it live right so things are
fast-paced we're in the moment it's
heated arguments happening and we do it
live that being said
in that environment
he felt like he was being attacked
verbally and physically right so
naturally you're going to want to defend
yourself and do certain things now she
did hit him you know so that right there
is trigger triggering so he's going to
retaliate in a certain way
now regarding the whole uh fight
whatever mine was able to hold him back
and ho chris was able to hold her back
so nothing happened but it could have
been bad but we did it live you know we
didn't expect it to happen and that's
thing we'll have a live show you never
know what's gonna happen so in our
environment we all have a role to play
him is he's doing the sound equipment
he's doing like the helping people stay
apart i'm doing like the consoling all
that stuff so you know we have our part
to play yeah i mean it was under control
man like it was 100 under control like i
was able to get in there stop it like it
was 100 under control which is why i
didn't feel empathy because i'm like bro
it's under control like
it is what it is i mean
the reality is gonna be a really good
dad the reality is this it was safe yeah
how you feel
is really irrelevant because you were
you were safe like if you didn't feel
that way i'm sorry you might have felt
that way that's all it
saying hey i'm sorry that you felt this
way that's it okay but it was but it was
but it was a safe environment i can't
control how you feel you know what i'm
saying if you're going to cry and
hyperventilate and stuff like that's on
you that's not on me like i was
understanding you for how i feel i'm
just asking you too he's under control
it was under control well i will say
this you have a lot of ladies on the
show yeah and
10 i was there 10 at a time and they
were all well behaved
it is hard to
basically have to deal with everyone's
different feelings i'm not downplaying
if she felt [ __ ] unsafe i understand
that but it's basically if i can put
words in your mouth it's not your job to
have to make a girl feel a certain type
of way is that basically what you're
saying i mean here's the thing it was
under control
how everyone feels after the fact after
it's under control gotcha is on them but
it was 100 under control and just add to
it we all have a role split like i said
earlier my role is to make sure
everyone's cool calm yeah like protect
the the threat so it's like you know
you guys have a literal good cop bad cop
thing going on that's pretty clear yeah
and you used to be a cop at some of some
capacity right you used to be in law
enforcement yeah i'm a i was a former
special agent of a homeless group right
so i mean i've been through much worse
that's what i'm saying like it was under
control and we've we've had crazier
situations on the pod yeah you know what
i'm saying so the weapon's involved yeah
well let's let's move on from this topic
i wanted to address that do you feel
safe now amber i feel safe okay do you
want to want to give my own a little dap
real quick all right we're good